hoy tocaba hablar de medio ambiente uno
de los asuntos de interés común en los
que hielen anticipaba más margen para el
acuerdo la secretaria del tesoro ha
pedido a China más apoyo financiero a
los fondos internacionales que sufragan
las iniciativas verdes para que éstas
puedan ser más eficaces también ha
pedido que China y Estados Unidos
aumenten su cooperación ante la que ha
llamado amenaza existencial del cambio
climático el compromiso chino no se
discute doblará en 2025 su producción de
energía verde y alcanzará su compromiso
cinco años antes de lo previsto Además
ya tiene desplegados más paneles solares
que el resto del mundo juntos Pero
sostiene que son Estados Unidos y Europa
por su condición de máximos
contaminantes históricos los que tienen
que sufragar las iniciativas globales y
no los países en vías de desarrollo el
diálogo climático entre los dos mayores
emisores de gases de efecto invernadero
quedó interrumpido el pasado año tras la
visita Taiwán de la entonces presidenta
de la cámara de representantes Nancy
pelosi la próxima llegada a Pekín de
John Kerry enviado especial de asuntos
climáticos sugiere que ambos países
retomarán la comunicación yelen que hoy
se ha reunido con el viceprimer ministro
gelifeng ha señalado que el récord de
comercio bilateral alcanzado el pasado
año aún Incluso en un contexto de
hostilidades demuestra el potencial de
cooperación económica y también la
imposibilidad del desacoplamiento que
defendían las voces más extremas de
Washington pero yelen también aclarado
que la competición saludable necesita
reglas justas en una probable alusión a
los subsidios chinos a sus empresas
públicas y las barreras de acceso a su